David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-26 A and B. Apparently, the end which was on Spool 27 has been combined here with 26. This has to be checked again. October 22nd, 1950. Boder.
David Boder: July 5th 1946. [The correct date is August 5th.] Number 9 Rue Guy Patin. A home for adult displaced persons. Some the Jewish...
David Boder: [In German] Also, sagen Sie mir, wie lautet Ihr Name, Frau Button?
Eda Button: Deutsch sprechen?
David Boder: Auf Deutsch.
Eda Button: Ich heiße Eda Button. Ich war deportiert von Athen im, äh, April ’44.
David Boder: Und nach wo wurden sie deportiert?
Eda Button: Ich war deportiert in äh Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Ja. Also, sagen Sie mal, äh, wo ist Ihr Mann?
Eda Button: Mein Mann ist, äh, weggelau- war, äh, in, äh, Palästina, in Tel Aviv.
David Boder: Ist er jetzt in Tel Aviv?
Eda Button: Nein, wenn ich deportiert waren, war, mein Mann ist weggelaufen in Türkei und von Türkei in, äh, Palästina.
David Boder: Ja. Und, äh, ist er jetzt in Palästina?
Eda Button: Mein Mann ist in Tel Aviv in Palästina.
David Boder: Bekommen Sie Briefe von ihm?
Eda Button: Ja, ich bekomme. Und ich warte mein Permit...
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: nach, äh, Palästina zu fahren mit mein Kind.
David Boder: Aha. Ist das das einzige Kind, das Sie haben?
Eda Button: Das einzige Kind. Ich habe ihm von äh 11 Monate in, äh, [Anmerkung: unklar, vermutlich die Filles de la Charite de Saint-Vincent-de-Paul] in, äh, Saloniki gelassen.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer hat ihnen das Kind jetzt zurückgebracht?
Eda Button: Die Schwester, die Superieur von [Saint-Vincent?] von de Paul hat mir mein Kind selbst mit avion von, äh, Saloniki bis hier gebracht. Weil mein Kind war krank und schwach.
David Boder: Ja. [unverständlich]. Also, sagen Sie mir, äh, Frau Button. Ähm, Erzählen Sie mir die ganze Geschichte. Wie hat man Sie deportiert. Wie hat die Sache angefangen, wenn die Deutschen nach Griechenland gekommen sind. Sind Sie Spanisch?
Eda Button: Ich bin Spanier ich war, äh, Grieche, von, äh, von Griechenland.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Mein Mann war Grieche aber ich war Spanier als Mädchen.
David Boder: Als Mädchen waren Sie Spanier.
Eda Button: War ich Spanier. Und dann haben wir uns
David Boder: Sind Sie in Spanien geboren?
Eda Button: Nee, nee. Ich bin in Saloniki geboren, in Griechenland.
David Boder: Ja
Eda Button: Und wir haben uns, äh, divorcé?
David Boder: Sie haben sich geschieden.
Eda Button: Geschieden mit mein Mann, um mit die spanische Nationalität zu haben um nicht, äh, nach äh Deutschland, äh, zu deportieren.
David Boder: Ja, wieso? War Ihr Mann von spanische Nationalität?
Eda Button: Mein Mann war Grieche.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Griechische Nationalität und er musste nach, äh
David Boder: Ja, und warum haben Sie sich dann scheiden müssen?
Eda Button: Weil man hat, äh, früher in, äh, Griechenland gesagt, dass die Spanier und die Italiener wollten nicht äh deportiert
David Boder: Hmhm.
Eda Button: [sie korrigiert sich] würden nicht deportiert.
David Boder: Aha. So haben Sie sich von ihrem Mann geschieden...
Eda Button: [unterbrich] geschieden
David Boder: . . . und Sie sind, äh, wieder Spanierin geworden.
Eda Button: Spanierin geworden.
David Boder: Aber sagen Sie, äh, Sie haben sich nicht von anderen Gründen geschieden?
Eda Button: Nein, nein nur für dieses.
David Boder: Nur für dieses.
Eda Button: Für diesen Grund, um mein Kind zu retten.
David Boder: Ja. Nun lasst die Kleine uns was vor-äh, vorsagen oder vorsingen, wollen wir mal sehen.
Eda Button: Tu sais quelque chose que tu veut chanter? La petite chose.
Eda Button: [Mutter singt ein Lied vor. Das Kind singt ‚Drei Chinesen mit dem Kontrabass’ in Französisch. Das Lied ist ein deutsches Kinderlied.]
David Boder: [In English] Sing something else with your mother together. Sing something else with your mother together, huh?
Eda Button: [Kind und Mutter singen das Lied ‚Battle Hymn of the Republic’, in Griechisch. Das Kind singt ein Kinderlied auf die Melodie von ‚She’ll be Coming Round the Mountain’, in Griechisch]
David Boder: [In German] Man hat die Kleine operiert diese Woche? Wovon hat man sie operiert?
Eda Button: Von, äh, Mandeln und von die Nase.
David Boder: Oh, man hat sie von den Mandeln und von der Nase. Die Polypen hat man rausgenommen.
Eda Button: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: [an jemand anderen im Raum] Äh, schicken Sie sie nach oben rauf. Äh
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir mal, Frau Button. Also wann hat man angefangen die Juden in Griechenland zu verfolgen?
Eda Button: In ’42 hat man angefangen, wirklich.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Weil man musste im, äh, im, äh, Ghetto gehen.
David Boder: Haben sie ein Ghetto in Griechenland gehabt?
Eda Button: Ja, am Ende für ’42.
David Boder: In welcher Stadt war das?
Eda Button: In Saloniki.
David Boder: Und was war ihr Manns Geschäft?
Eda Button: Mein Mann war Advokat.
David Boder: Ihr Mann war ein Advokat [zusammen] in Saloniki. Wo hat er studiert?
Eda Button: In, äh, Universität. Griechische Universität in Saloniki und Athen.
David Boder: Er hat in der griechischen Universität in Saloniki und Athen studiert und war Advokat.
Eda Button: Ja.
David Boder: Äh, und wie lange waren sie verheiratet wenn sie, bis wenn die Deutschen kamen?
Eda Button: Ich bin ’39, äh, 22. Oktober ’39 verheiratet.
David Boder: Verheiratet.
Eda Button: Und ein Jahr...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Ja?
Eda Button: . . . ein Jahr später sind die Deutschen schon gekommen.
David Boder: Ja, und wann wurde das Kind geboren?
Eda Button: Mein Kind ist in ’42, Mai ’42 geboren.
David Boder: Das Kind wurde im Mai ’42 geboren. Nun, sagen Sie mal, äh, wann äh, wann sind die Deutschen gekommen und was haben die Deutschen von den Juden verlangt?
Eda Button: Man hat verlangt, wir müssen unsere Häuser lassen, unsere Möbel alle und wir müssen in, äh, Ghetto sch- äh gehen. Man hat verschiedene Straße mit äh wie sagt man das mit Sterne...
David Boder: Äh, mit
Eda Button: . . . mit, äh, Magen David?
David Boder: Ja mit Magen David bezeichnet.
Eda Button: Magen David bezeichnet. Und wir mü-, wir könnten nicht heraus von diese Straße gehen. Es war überall Polizei.
David Boder: Ja, aber
Eda Button: Und wir müssen auch die Sterne tragen.
David Boder: Und sie müssen auch die Sterne tragen. Now. Wem haben die Häuser in diesen Straßen gehört?
Eda Button: Die, äh, die Juden. Meistens Juden und auch Griechen.
David Boder: Es war ein jüdisches Viertel?
Eda Button: Ja, ein jüdisches Viertel.
David Boder: Hat man die Griechen von dort ausgewiesen?
Eda Button: Nein, es war auch Grieche...
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: . . . aber besonders Jude und die Juden konnten nicht im Geschäft gehen. Und mein Mann war musste sein äh Büro lassen...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . und er musste die ganze Zeit in äh zu Hause bleiben.
David Boder: Aha.
Eda Button: Um zwölf Uhr musste alle Leute äh im äh Haus sein.
David Boder: Ja. Nun. Und wovon haben sie denn gelebt?
Eda Button: Mit, äh, was wir hatten. Wir haben unsere Sachen, was wir gerettet haben, wir haben das für die Griechen für, äh, für, äh, nicht äh...
David Boder: Für eine Kleinigkeit
Eda Button: . . . für Kleinigkeit, äh...
David Boder: Verkauft...
Eda Button: . . . verkauft. Und von das...
David Boder: . . . haben sie gelebt.
Eda Button: . . . haben sie gelebt.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und wir müssen mit vier, vier Personen in ein Zimmer sein.
David Boder: Wieso? Vier, äh, Männer und Frauen zusammen?
Eda Button: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und in einem Zimmer. Haben sie, wie viel Betten haben sie gehabt?
Eda Button: Eine konnte unten schlafen in einem Zimmer, in Bett [unverständlich]. Eine Familie in ein Zimmer.
David Boder: Ja. Und wann wurde das Kind geboren?
Eda Button: Mein Kind war schon geboren.
David Boder: Ah.
Eda Button: Hatte damals, äh, 11 Monate.
David Boder: Das Kind war 11 Monate, wenn sie ins Ghetto gingen. Nun gut. Und wann haben Sie sich dann beschlossen, von ihrem Mann zu scheiden?
Eda Button: [räuspert sich] Wenn mein Kind 10 Monate hatte...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . mein Mann war Advokat, und er hatte gesagt, wenn, wenn, äh, man hatte damals gesagt, dass die Spanischen und die Italiener...
Eda Button: ,...ko-, wurden nicht deportiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und mein Mann als Advokat hatte gedacht, wir sollen uns entschieden...
David Boder: Scheiden.
Eda Button: . . . entscheiden. Und so würde ich wieder äh Spanisch werden. Und ich konnte meine äh, meine fortune, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Ihre [unverständlich]. Was, Sie konnten was?
Eda Button: Meine fortune, mein Vermögen...
David Boder: Ihr Vermögen ja.
Eda Button: . . . ihr Vermögen retten...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: ,...und mein Kind auch.
Eda Button: Aber, äh, wir müssen
David Boder: [unterbricht] Und wenn Sie sich geschieden haben, haben sie dann miteinander gewohnt?
Eda Button: Nein. Nicht mehr mit mein Mann aber nur für andere Papiere.
David Boder: Nur andere Papiere. Und hat das geholfen?
Eda Button: Das hat nicht geholfen.
David Boder: Das hat nicht geholfen.
Eda Button: Mein Mann musste weg-, weggehen, laufen...
David Boder: Aha
Eda Button: . . . weil wir brauchten damals, 24 Millionen hat man verlangt, um die drei zu retten.
David Boder: 24 Millionen Drachmen.
Eda Button: Millionen Drachmen.
David Boder: 24 Millionen.
Eda Button: Millionen Drachmen hat man uns, ähm...
David Boder: Verlangt, um sie zu retten.
Eda Button: . . . verlangt, um die drei Personen zu retten. Mein Mann und ich und mein kleines Kind.
David Boder: Ja, haben Sie das Geld gehabt?
Eda Button: Nee, wir haben kein Geld gehabt. Was ich hatte, es waren Haus und, äh, terre wie sagt man?
David Boder: Und Land.
Eda Button: Und Land. Und ich konnte, ich hatte kein Geld.
David Boder: Aha, äh.
Eda Button: Und dann mein Mann ist in Berg weggelaufen, mein Kind hat eine italienische Frau gerettet, sie hat mein Kind in die Kirche gelassen.
David Boder: Was heißt in der Kirche gelassen?
Eda Button: Sie hat, um sechs Uhr abends, ist sie gekommen. Sie hat mein Kind genommen. Sie hat ein, ein Papier auf die, äh...
David Boder: Die Brust gelegt.
Eda Button: auf die Brust gelegt, dass sie heißt Gilbelle und sie ist katholisch und sie hat ein kleines croix, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Ein Kreuz.
Eda Button: Ein Kreuz getan und etwas, dass mir, dass wir das Kind, äh, reconnaitre, dass wir sehen...
David Boder: Ja, dass sie das Kind äh erkennen können.
Eda Button: . . . erkennen können.
David Boder: Was hat sie raufgelegt, dass sie das Kind erkennen können?
Eda Button: Sie hat gele-, äh, getan ein Papier. Und sie hat geschrieben Gilbette [Anmerkung: Der Name ist undeutlich, entweder ‚Gilbelle’ oder ‚Gilbette’], katholisch, der liebe Gott soll sie helfen, soll sie retten. Und ein kleines Kreuz und dann etwas, damit wir das Kind, äh, erkennen.
David Boder: Erkennen. Was hat sie reingelegt, dass Sie das Kind erkennen sollen?
Eda Button: Ein, äh, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Medaillon?
Eda Button: Ein Medaillon, ja.
David Boder: Ein Medaillon.
Eda Button: Aber ein Stück war weg.
David Boder: Aha.
Eda Button: Und ich hatte das Stück.
David Boder: Schon gut, und Sie hatten das Stück.
Eda Button: Das Stück.
David Boder: War es ein Stück Metall?
Eda Button: Metall, ja.
David Boder: Und Sie haben das Stück Metall dann abgebrochen und mitgenommen?
Eda Button: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann hat sie das Kind einfach in der Kirche gelassen?
Eda Button: In der Kirche gelassen. Aber sie war schon einverstanden mit die Superieur [von Saint-Vincent?] von de-Paul, von diese, äh, couvent...
David Boder: Ja, von diesem Konvent, ja.
Eda Button: Konvent. Und man hat das Kind in die Kirche gelassen um sechs Uhr, und die Frau ist weggelaufen, und dann hat man das Kind genommen.
David Boder: So. Und, äh, dann, was hat ihnen passiert?
Eda Button: [räuspert sich] Ich habe mich drei Monate versteckt.
David Boder: Oh, sie sind vom Ghetto weggegangen?
Eda Button: Vom Ghetto.
David Boder: Ihr Mann ist weggegangen und das Kind war untergebracht mit den Schwestern und Sie haben sich versteckt. Ja.
Eda Button: Und alle Griechen von Saloniki waren deportiert.
David Boder: Alle griechischen Juden.
Eda Button: Alle griechische Juden. War jede zwei, drei Tage waren, äh, Deportationen...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . von [unklar, wahrscheinlich ‚Baldad’] das ist dort ein Lager...
Eda Button: . . . in, äh, Deutschland, in Auschwitz.
David Boder: In Auschwitz.
Eda Button: Auschwitz.
David Boder: Und dann, wenn hat man sie festgenommen wieder? Sie haben sich versteckt?
Eda Button: Ich habe mich versteckt drei Monate.
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: Dann ist ein Grieche gekommen. Und ich habe mit meine [unverständlich] geredet hatte. Ich hab alles verkauft, ich habe ihm Geld gegeben und er hat mir mit griechische Papiere, griechische [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . er hat mir genommen, dass ich seine Frau war, und dann sind wir gelaufen von Saloniki bis Athen sind wir, äh, von Dorf zu Dorf mit, äh, Pferd und so...
Eda Button: Zwanzig Tage von Saloniki bis Athen.
David Boder: Gelaufen.
Eda Button: Gelaufen.
David Boder: Wie lang dauert es, anders von Saloniki bis Athen zu fahren?
Eda Button: Ein Tag.
David Boder: Ein Tag. Und Sie sind zwanzig Tage gefahren?
Eda Button: Zwanzig Tage.
David Boder: Und er war ein christlicher Grieche?
Eda Button: Ein christlicher Grieche.
David Boder: Nun, und so hat er sie mitgenommen und dann sind sie nach Athen gekommen.
Eda Button: Athen gekommen. In Athen, in Athen war besetzt von Italiener. Und die Italiener haben nicht dasselbe, was man in Saloniki gemacht hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Die haben nicht appliquer le lois martiale.
David Boder: Ja. Also, so waren Sie in Athen [unverständlich]. Ja. Was ist in Athen passiert?
Eda Button: In Athen habe ich meine Schwester gefunden, die da jahrelang hat dorthin gewohnt.
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: Und, äh, ich bin dorthin geblieben und, äh, vier Tage später mein ist Mann von Berg gekommen, um Nachrichten von mich und mein Kind zu, zu haben.
Eda Button: Da hat er mir gefunden. Und er hat, äh, gewusst, dass mein Kind dort zu die katholische...
David Boder: Konvent.
Eda Button: . . . geblieben ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und mein Mann war sehr krank, und für das hat man ihn vom Berg in Athen gebracht und zwei Monate ist er, äh, in Hospital geblieben.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann?
Eda Button: Und dann habe ich, weil ich hatte keine Papiere, ich war nicht, noch nicht Spanisch.
David Boder: Und der Grieche, der Sie mitgenommen hatte, ist weggegangen?
Eda Button: Er ist weggegangen und ich habe ihm ein Papier unterschrieben, dass ich nach dem Kriege, ich wollte ihm noch 5, äh, 10 [unverständlich] noch geben.
David Boder: Ja, hmhm.
Eda Button: Und er ist, er hat mir, er war, er hat mir gelassen und er ist weg.
Eda Button: Und dann bin ich, haben wir, habe ich, äh, ich habe sehr viel gelitten. Mein Mann war im Hospital und ich hatte kein Geld.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und mein Mann, wenn er ‘sund? [Anmerkung: sie sagt wohl ein falsches Wort für ‚gesund’] war, er hat angefangen...
David Boder: Wenn er gesund war.
Eda Button: . . . wenn er gesund war, hat er angefangen, um [unverständlich], wie sagt man? Er hat angefangen, so, äh, Sachen zu...
David Boder: Zu verkaufen.
Eda Button: . . . zu verkaufen von ein [unverständlich] damit man ein Stück Brot, äh...
David Boder: Hatte.
Eda Button: . . . hatte. Und wir sind geblie-, wir sind, äh, wir waren noch in eine, in das Haus von meiner Schwester.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Dann hat man, äh, sechs Monate später ist auch meine Mutter von Athen, von Saloniki auch weggelaufen in Athen.
Eda Button: Und wir haben alle zusammen gewohnt.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Acht Tage, acht Monate später hat, äh, ist der Mussolini...
David Boder: Ja, Mussolini wurde beseitigt.
Eda Button: . . . wurde beseitigt. Und die Deutschen waren wieder in Athen und, äh, von Gestapo der, äh, Chef war wieder in Athen und er hat dasselbe Sachen, das man in Saloniki gemacht hat, hat man wieder in Athen angefangen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und wir müssen wieder meine, äh, das Haus meiner Schwester lassen und wieder haben wir uns versteckt von hier und von dort.
David Boder: Und wo ist Ihre Schwester gegangen?
Eda Button: Meine Schwester hat sich versteckt in eine, äh, kleine Wohnung mit ein Mann.
David Boder: Mit ihrem Mann, ja?
Eda Button: Mit ihrem Mann und mit ihm die vier Kinder.
David Boder: Aha.
Eda Button: Und die zwei große Kinder, zwei von 18 und 20 Jahre, man hatte damals gesagt, dass wer verheirat mit ein Christ war, konnten sie sich retten.
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: Und, äh, wir haben gedacht, dass [versuchen?], für die Mädchen zu retten, würden sie, dass sie ein mariage blanc, eine...
David Boder: Falsche.
Eda Button: . . . eine falsche...
David Boder: Heirat machen.
Eda Button: Heirat machen. Und ich, ich habe angefangen, weil damals ich hatte schon meine spanische Papiere, ich war frei. Und ich hab angefangen, für zwei Herren zu finden, griechische Herren, die wollten meine Nichte heiraten.
David Boder: Bloß als mariage blanc?
Eda Button: Nur...
David Boder: Um sie zu retten, ja.
Eda Button: . . . nur um die Kinder zu re-, die Mädchen zu retten, damit sie arische Papiere bekommen, und sie konnten, äh, arbeiten um die ganze Familie zu, äh...
David Boder: Ernähren und unterstützen.
Eda Button: . . . zu ernähren.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Weil der Vater lag auch versteckt wie die Mutter.
David Boder: Ja. Von ihrer Schwester.
Eda Button: Meine Schwester, ja.
David Boder: Und so?
Eda Button: Und dann habe ich gedacht, weil mein Mann noch war in dieselbe, ich war Spanisch, ich war, ich hatte geglaubt, dass ich war gerettet.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich hab angefangen, eine Frau für meinen Mann auch zu finden.
David Boder: Ja, eine christliche Frau.
Eda Button: Eine christliche Frau. Und wir haben ein Fräulein gefunden von 22 Jahre und dieses Fräulein hat, sie war eine Kommunist, und sie hat, äh...
David Boder: Äh, sie war einverstanden.
Eda Button: . . . einverstanden, dass sie wollte meinen Mann heiraten.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und man musste...
David Boder: Auch so eine mariage blanc?
Eda Button: Mariage blanc. Am sechsten Oktober mussten alle mariages blancs in die jüdische Gemeinde deklar-, deklarier- wie sagt man?
David Boder: Äh, deklariert werden.
Eda Button: Deklariert werden. Und es war schon fünfzehnten [Anmerkung: logisch wäre hier der fünfte.] Oktober und mein Mann hatte noch keine Frau gefunden.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Am letzten Moment haben wir, dieses Fräulein war einverstanden und sie sind, äh, sie haben alles schnell gemacht...
Eda Button: . . . und so haben sie sich verheiratet.
David Boder: Verheiratet.
Eda Button: Verheiratet.
David Boder: Ja. Hmhm.
Eda Button: Und dann, dann ist er wieder zurück zu mir gekommen in mein Haus...
David Boder: Ja
Eda Button: . . . und ich war, wenn, äh, wenn die Polizei würde kommen, ich war Spanische und, äh, entschieden von mein Mann und ich konnte, ich musste nicht mit meinem Mann leben.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Weil er war, er war verheiratet mit eine Grieche.
David Boder: Ja, hmhm.
Eda Button: Und dann wir hatten geglaubt, dass mein Mann war gerettet.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: An, äh, manche Monate. Dann, äh, wir haben unsere Haus gelassen...
David Boder: Hmhm.
Eda Button: . . . und wir sind, äh, in eine, mein Mann war in ein Büro ist er da abends geblieben und ich war in eine griechische, zu eine griechische Frau versteckt.
David Boder: Warum haben Sie sich wieder verstecken müssen, sie hatten doch Papiere [unverständlich]?
Eda Button: Ja, weil man hat angefangen, dass alle Juden müssen jede Woche die, äh, jüdische...[zusammen] Gemeinde...müssen sie sich deklarieren.
David Boder: Hmhm. Ob sie verheiratet sind zu Christen oder nicht.
Eda Button: Ja, äh.
David Boder: Ja, hmhm.
Eda Button: Und, äh, wir waren in eine, äh, in ein Haus von meine, eine wie sagt man, äh, belle soeur...
David Boder: Eine Schwägerin.
Eda Button: . . . eine Schwägerin.
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: Und wir haben dorthin gewohnt. Mein Mann ist oft gekommen, wir haben dorthin gewohnt.
David Boder: Warum war es sicher bei Ihrer Schwägerin? War sie nicht jüdisch?
Eda Button: Nein, äh, sie war Jüdin, aber sie war, äh, mit, äh, falsche Papiere, äh, deklariert.
David Boder: Als Christin, ja.
Eda Button: Als Christin deklariert, von ihrem Mann.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Und dann haben Sie mit ihr gewohnt.
Eda Button: Wir haben gewohnt.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Dann haben wir ein Herr, ein jüdische Herr haben wir gekannt [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja?
Eda Button: . . . und wir wussten nicht, dass dieser jüdische Herr war einverstanden mit die Deutsche.
David Boder: [überrascht] Oh, er war mit den Gestapo verbündet.
Eda Button: Mit den Gestapo [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und...[kurze Pause]
David Boder: Und?
Eda Button: Manche, äh, Tage später er hatte sich auch entscheiden lassen mit seine Frau.
David Boder: Ja er hat sich scheiden lassen.
Eda Button: Entscheiden lassen mit seine Frau. Und seine Frau war mit einem Christen verheiratet und er auch mit eine Christ. Und dann hat er mein Mann gesagt, „warum nur, äh, machst Du auch, dass deine Frau auch mit eine Christ heiratet...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . warum machst du das nicht?“
Eda Button: Mein Mann hat mir, äh, gefragt, „willst du das, dass du auch mit eine Christ, äh, [zusammen]. Ich habe gesagt „nein, ich hab so viel Angst, in die Kirche zu gehen, und alles was man machen muss...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . was man braucht. Und ich werde so bleiben. Vielleicht wird das Krieg schon zu Ende sein und ich werde mich so retten.“
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Eda Button: Das war in, äh, Anfang ’44.
David Boder: Anfang ’44, hmhm?
Eda Button: Später ist meine, meine, äh, Schwiegermutter...
David Boder: Schwiegermutter, ja.
Eda Button: Schwiegermutter.
David Boder: Ihr, ihren Manns Mutter.
Eda Button: Manns Mutter mit mein Schwieger-, äh...
David Boder: Schwägerin
Eda Button: . . . -vater.
David Boder: Mit Schwiegervater.
Eda Button: Mit Schwiegervater. Sie waren in ein Dorf versteckt. Mein Schwiegervater war von 80 Jahre...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . und meine Schwiegermutter war von äh 70 Jahre.
Eda Button: Und sie sind weggelaufen von Dorf zu Dorf. Weil sie waren von, aus Griechenland und sie haben sehr gut die Sprache gekannt...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . die griechische Sprache. Und so dass konnten sie sich retten.
David Boder: Hmhm?
Eda Button: Und sie sind in Athen gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und wir haben zusammen, alle gewohnt zu, äh, meiner Schwiegerschwester.
Eda Button: Dann, ein Tag haben wir gehört dass dieser Herr, der bei uns gekommen ist, war, äh, war einverstanden mit die Deutsche.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und, äh, ich, ich wir haben Angst gehabt mein Mann und ich und wir sind weggelaufen in ein andere Schwieger-, äh, Schwiegerschwester...
David Boder: Zu einer anderen Schwägerin.
Eda Button: Schwägerin, Schwägerin, die auch in Athen wohnt in ein andere Quartier.
David Boder: Ja, hmhm?
Eda Button: Und meine Schwiegermutter ist geblieben mit die andere Schwägerin.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und, der, der jüdisches Herr, er hat ein wenig übel genommen, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Es hat ihm leid getan?
Eda Button: Leid getan am Ende. Und er hat meine Schwiegermutter gesagt, „Du sollst, ich weiß nicht was, die Deutschen wissen, dass Ihr wohnt in dieses Haus. Und heute werden die Deutschen kommen und Euch
David Boder: Euch festnehmen?
Eda Button: Festnehmen“.
David Boder: Hat dieser jüdische Herr etwas zu Ihnen Schlechtes getan?
Eda Button: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat er getan?
Eda Button: Weil ich habe Angst gehabt und ich habe ihm eine Kleinigkeit, die ich gerettet hatte von Saloniki, so Wäsche und Kleider, und ich musste alles nach ihm geben...
David Boder: Und weglaufen?
Eda Button: . . . um, ja, wegzulaufen, ich hatte keine Haus zu bleiben und nichts.
David Boder: Aha. Und dann hat er Ihrer Schwiegermutter gesagt...
Eda Button: Nein, er hat meinem Schwieger-...
David Boder: . . . -mutter?
Eda Button: . . . -bruder gesagt
David Boder: Ihrem Schwager?
Eda Button: Meinem Schwager, auch ein Advokat...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . dass die Deutschen würden, äh...
David Boder: Kommen?
Eda Button: Kommen, in Haus kommen. Und er sollte sich retten, weglaufen. Aber die Mutter, weil sie ja alt war, und der Vater konnten im Haus bleiben.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Aber im Moment, da mein, mein Schwager das gesagt hat, er ist weg von zu Hause gekommen, und er hat meine Schwieger-...
David Boder: Vater?
Eda Button: . . . vater und meine Schwiegermutter, die noch im Tisch waren...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Eda Button: . . . im Speisezimmer. . .
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . hat er gesagt, [schleunigst?] soll sie, äh...
David Boder: Weglaufen?
Eda Button: Weglaufen, und mein Schwiegervater hatte keine Zeit, meine Jacke, etwas anzuziehen und meine Schwiegerschwester und sie sind weggelaufen von die, die, die Treppe von [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Von hinten, ja.
Eda Button: . . . von hinten. Und im Moment, das sie war, sie sind weggelaufen, sie haben noch das Licht brennen gelassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und dann meine Schwiegerbruder er ist weggelaufen mit seiner Frau. Da ist er zu der Jude, der das [unverständlich] wollte, das ihm gesagt, sie sind schon weggelaufen. Da hat der Jude gesagt, “Und Deine Mutter ist auch weggelaufen?” Hat er gesagt “Ja, natürlich - konnte mich nicht retten, und meine Mutter und mein Vater lassen”. Da hat er gesagt “Was hast Du gemacht? Die Deutschen werden verstehen, dass ich habe Euch gesagt, sie sollen weglaufen”.
David Boder: Das war der christliche [könnte auch „hilfreiche“ heißen] Mensch?
Eda Button: Der Jude.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Er war ein Jude.
David Boder: [überrascht] Ach, er war ein Jude, der mit den Deutschen gearbeitet hat?
Eda Button: Ja, ja. Er war ein Jude.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Ein griechischer Jude.
David Boder: Ein griechischer Jude, der mit den Deutschen gearbeitet hat? Nun?
Eda Button: Und er hat gesagt, “Was haben Sie gemacht? Die Deutschen werden verstehen, dass ich habe Euch das gesagt, und was hätten wir machen”. Da hat mein Schwager gesagt, “Ich konnte meine Mutter nicht lassen, mein Vater, ein 80jähriger Mensch, im so lassen”. Und dann wir sind weggelaufen. Da sind wir wieder die, der, mein Schwager, und meine Schwägerin, äh nicht der Schwager...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . der Schwiegervater...
Eda Button: . . . mein Schwiegermutter sind zu uns gekommen, wo wir hatten nur eine Küche mit zwei Zimmern, wo wir waren schon 6, 8 Personen. Und, äh, eine hat sich im Bett im Boden gelegt und so sind wir manche Tage wieder geblieben.
David Boder: Und dann wie wurden Sie deportiert?
Eda Button: Ich war deportiert, wo/obwohl [unklar] mein Mann hatte gesagt, dass ich fahren musste in Barcelona fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und weil der erste Gruppe von Saloniki, von spanische Gruppe, war fünf [evtl. auch „zwölf“] Monate in Belsen, dann waren sie von Frankfurt...
Eda Button: . . . waren sie in Barcelona, wirklich in Barcelona, und wir haben Briefe von ihnen erhal...
David Boder: Bekommen?
Eda Button: . . . bekommen, dass sie waren schon in Barcelona. Man hat uns damals gesagt, dass alle Juden von, spanische Juden von Athen würden wieder gerade nach Barcelona fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Da hat mir mein Mann gesagt, „warum willst Du Dich noch verstecken, wenn [unverständlich], dass man der Vater und gerade nach Auschwitz. . .
David Boder: Geschickt?
Eda Button: . . . geschicken. Warum willst Du dann machen, wenn Du auch nicht nach, äh, Barcelona.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Einen Monat wirst Du in Barcelona bleiben, Weltkrieg wird beenden...
Eda Button: . . . und Du wirst wieder zurückkommen. Und ich fahr im Sonntag, äh, nicht Sonntag, [fragend] dimanche [unverständlich]?
David Boder: Ja, Montag.
Eda Button: Am Montag war ich im spanischen Konsulat und, zum Fragen, was der spanische, was muss ich machen. Weil alle Spanier waren schon deklariert, und alle waren schon im jüdische Gemeinde. Und dann hat er gesagt, am Sonntag müssen sie um 9 Uhr, müssen sie alle nach Spanien fahren.
David Boder: Nach Spanien?
Eda Button: Nach Spanien fahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich bin gegangen im Konsulat zu fragen, was ich machten muss, machen muss. Dort war ein katholischer, äh, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Priester? Minister?
Eda Button: Ein, ja...
David Boder: Padre?
Eda Button: . . . ich sage doch schon, und der wusste, dass mein Kind war versteckt in Saloniki.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und er hat zu mir gesagt, “Was brauchst Du noch hier zu sein. [unverständlich] von einem Haus zu einem andern. Und es ist besser, Du sollst nach Spanien fahren. Dort wirst Du frisches Luft atmen und frei sein und ein Monat später wirst Du zurückkommen“.
Eda Button: Und am Ende [?] ich habe auch der Konsul gefragt. Der Konsul hat zu mir gesagt, „Für Dich ist das Beste, musst Du nach Spanien fahren.“
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: „In acht, äh, fünf Tagen werden Sie in Barcelona sein und Sie werden frei sein.“ Dann bin ich zu Hause gekommen, mit der Pfarrer...
David Boder: Mit dem Pfarrer?
Eda Button: Ja, mit dem Pfarrer bin ich zu Hause gekommen. Mit das Auto von der...
David Boder: Konsulat?
Eda Button: . . . Konsulat. Ich sollte etwas, eine Valise nehmen, etwas Wäsche, etwas für mich abholen. Und ich bin zu Hause gekommen und ich hatte keine Zeit, meinem Mann zu sagen, dass ich werde wegfahren. Weil in einer Viertel Stunde musste man—[pause]—schon im Bahnhof sein, weil der Zug musste wegfahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Weg. Ich bin zu Hause gekommen, und mein Mann hatte keine Zeit, nicht einmal mehr, zu hören was los war. Ich habe so eine paar Sachen genommen, keine Zeit, und ich bin mit dem Padre im Auto gefahren. Wir sind zum, wieder in Konsulat gegangen und der Minister spanische Konsul mit seiner Frau ist auch, war dort, äh, er hat uns gewartet und alle zusammen sind wir im Bahnhof gekommen. Bin ich im Bahnhof, äh, der Auto, äh, der [arreté?]. . .
David Boder: Sind zurückgegangen?
Eda Button: Nein, [unverständlich]
David Boder: Geblieben? [unverständlich]
Eda Button: Ja, und sind, ich habe angefangen zu weinen. Ich habe der Konsul gesagt, „ich will nicht wegfahren“. Hat er gesagt, “Nein, das Beste ist, weil sie sollen [nach] Spanien fahren. Und in einen Monat ist schon der Krieg zu Ende und Sie werden zurückkommen”.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Habe ich der Padre gebetet, er sollte, er sollte, sich kümmern für meine Kind in, äh...
David Boder: Im Konvent?
Eda Button: In Salonika. Ja, im Konvent. Hat er gesagt, “Ja, ja, Du wirst zurück sein, und Du kannst Dich...“
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nun [unverständlich], und wie sind Sie dann weggegangen?
Eda Button: Ich bin gekommen im Bahnhof, und ich habe angefangen zu gehen.
David Boder: Und waren dort schon andere Juden?
Eda Button: Nein, wir waren nicht von die rechte Seite, wir waren von die andere Seite hin gekommen. Wir wussten nicht, wo die spanischen Juden waren. Da haben wir gesehen, dass alle Wagone waren schon mit barbelé, wie sagt man?
David Boder: Mit Draht?
Eda Button: Mit Draht.
David Boder: Mit Draht. Ja?
Eda Button: Und ich habe nicht Juden, Juden gesehen. Ich habe vom Fenster von die Drahte
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Ich habe gesagt “Das ist jetzt [unverständlich], dürfen wir reisen. Ich habe Angst und ich will zurückkommen in Athen. Ich will nicht reisen. Ich will nicht weggehen”.
Eda Button: Da hat mir die Frau von der spanische Konsul gesagt, “Sie haben recht, aber die Deutschen haben uns falsch gesagt, man hat uns gesagt, dass Sie müssen mit 2. Klasse...”
David Boder: Mit 2. Wagon fahren?
Eda Button: . . . mit 2. Klasse Wagon fahren. Und die Deutschen haben uns...
David Boder: [In English] The spool ended and I am making an attachment so that this spool will have probably more than 33 minutes. The story is becoming interesting and I decided to continue.
David Boder: [In German] Also, sagen Sie mal, dann sind sie dort gewesen, fangen Sie noch mal an. Ja?
Eda Button: Ich war im Bahnhof gewesen und ich habe die Juden gesehen, die sie in Wagon gestritten [sic!] war mit Drahte. Ich hab so Angst gehabt, ich habe angefangen zu weinen. Da habe ich gefragt...
David Boder: Da hat die Frau vom...
Eda Button: Ich habe die Frau vom Spanische Konsul gesagt, “Wo sind jetzt die Wagon von 2. Klasse? Ich kann nicht so fahren. Und ich will zurück in Athen...”
David Boder: Nach Athen?
Eda Button: Nach Athen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Hat sie mir gesagt, “Sie haben recht, die Gestapo haben falsch gesagt. Und Sie können sich, Sie können zurückkommen”.
Eda Button: Und langsam, langsam bin ich gegang-, bin ich zurückgegangen, und der Konsul mit seiner Frau, und sein Sekretär und der Padre...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . sind, sind im Zug gegangen um der spanische Gruppe zu grüßen. Die die fort musste nach Spanien...
Eda Button: . . . wurden sie im letzten Moment grüßten.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich war [bisher?] im Auto.
Eda Button: Ich wusste nicht, was ich machen soll, weil es war deutsche Polizei.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich dachte, was soll ich antworten, wenn sie meine Papiere fragen, verlangen.
David Boder: War da kein Chauffeur?
Eda Button: Ja, der Chauffeur auch war, äh, er ist auch gegangen, um die spanische Gruppe zu grüßen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Denn er hat alle [unverständlich].
Eda Button: Und ich bin geblieben. Und dann, äh, manche Minute später der Pfarrer ist zurückgekommen, da hat er mir gesagt, “warum bist du da?” Ich hab gesagt, “ich habe Angst und ich will nicht fahren. Und ich will zurück nach Athen”. Da hat er mir gesagt, “Und, ich werde, Du kannst nicht hier draußen bleiben. Die Deutschen können Dich Deine Papiere verlangen - komm drin in der Auto”. Und ich bin im Auto gegang-, gekommen, ich bin, ich habe mich gesessen. Und ich hab so Angst gehabt, dass die Deutschen mich meine Papiere nicht verlangen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Aber weil die spanische Fahne war im Auto...
Eda Button: . . . ich hab gedacht, dass die Deutschen konnten nicht halt, äh...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . die Papiere verlangen. Und ich war dort, ich hab gewartet. Manche Minuten später, ich hab so Angst gehabt, ich hab gewartet, dass die, der Konsul und
David Boder: Seine Frau?
Eda Button: Grüßen, ja, grüßen die spanische Gruppe und dass er zurückkommt, um mich nach Athen wieder...
David Boder: Zurückzubringen?
Eda Button: . . . zurückzubringen. Manche Minute später ich seh, dass mein Bruder kommt. Mein Bruder war auch in Wagon mit meiner alte Mutter von achtzig Jahre.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Als Spanier wieder.
Eda Button: Und mein Bruder ist gekommen und er hat mir gefragt, warum bleib ich da, und warum, warum...
David Boder: [Unterbrechung; Boder scheint mit einer anderen Person im Hintergrund zu sprechen.]
Eda Button: Warum, mein Bruder hat mir gesagt, “warum bleibst Du da? Der Padre hat mir gesagt, dass Du hier bist und Du bist bis hier gekommen, und Du sollst mit uns nach Spanien fahren. Und wenn Du wieder nach Athen fahren, äh...”
David Boder: Zurückkehren?
Eda Button: . . . äh, willst, man wird Dich wieder, also...
David Boder: Verraten?
Eda Button: Wieder verraten und damals wirst Du gerade in Auschwitz...
David Boder: Gehen.
Eda Button: . . . gehen”. Und er sagte, “Musst Du mit uns kommen, wir fahren nach Spanien. Wir haben viel Brot im Zug.
David Boder: Im Zug, ja.
Eda Button: Und man hat alle Ernährung von, von alle Juden haben Geld gegeben und man hat uns, man hat viele Ernährung gekauft. Und wir werden ganz eine gute Reise machen. Und du sollst nicht, äh...
David Boder: Angst haben?
Eda Button: Angst haben, Du sollst mitkommen”. Er hat meine Valise genommen und wir sind gekommen. [Unverständlich, bin ich zu] der Zug gekommen, den ich gesehen habe, der Wagon von meiner Mutter, alte Mutter, und...
David Boder: Wo war Ihr Vater?
Eda Button: Mein Vater war schon lange gestorben. Bedauerlich.
David Boder: Ach so.
Eda Button: Und ich habe meine Mutter gesehen, und meinen Bruder und alle Leute, die dort [drin] waren. Sie waren meistens die reichsten jüdischen Familie von Griechenland.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich habe alle Leute gesehen. Ich habe gesagt, was habe ich gemacht, warum bin ich gekommen.
David Boder: Aha.
Eda Button: Aber zwei Minuten später der Zug musste schon weg und ich habe nur der Zeit gehabt, der Padre zu sagen, er sollte aufpassen auf mein Kind.
David Boder: Nun, Ihre [unverständlich]. Nach wo, äh wohin hat man Sie genommen?
Eda Button: Man hat mir genommen von Athen.
David Boder: Wohin, wo hin?
Eda Button: In, nach Bergen-Belsen. Man hat mich...
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nicht nach Spanien?
Eda Button: Nein. Es war falsch. Man hat uns gesagt, dass wir würden nach Spanien, aber wir fahren in Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Aha. Und wie lange waren Sie in Bergen-Belsen?
Eda Button: Ich war äh [überlegt] genau, äh, von, von 12. April ’44 sind wir von Athen und wir sind in Bergen-Belsen nach 14 Tage mit dem...
David Boder: [unterbricht] ja, und wie lange waren Sie dort?
Eda Button: Und wir waren bis 5. April ’45...
David Boder: ’45.
Eda Button: . . . sind wir dann dort hin, in Bergen-Belsen..
David Boder: [unterbricht] Nun, sagen Sie mal, wie haben Sie Ihr Kind zurückbekommen hier in Paris?
Eda Button: Bin ich, wir waren so, so lange in Belsen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und wir waren, wir hatten sehr schlechte Ernährung, äh...
Eda Button: . . . und alle schrecklich und jeder Monat ist der, äh, deutsche Chef ist er gekommen und er hat uns gesagt, noch ein wenig Geduld, noch ein paar Tage, dann wir nach Spanien fahren.
David Boder: Ja. Also, [unverständlich] Ich, äh, habe ich gehört, ich war gestern abend. Sie sagen, die “Mother Superior” hat Ihr Kind zurückgebracht.
Eda Button: Ja.
David Boder: Wer hat Ihre Reise bezahlt?
Eda Button: Ich, äh, ich habe verlangt von, meinen Mann, hat von Tel Aviv, hat er zu, ins Jerusalem geschrieben. Der Joint müssen uns helfen, um unsere Kind zu holen. Der Joint, ein Chef von einer, ein Direktor vom Joint hat mir ein Brief geschickt...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . und ich sollte doch hinkommen. Und, äh, der Direktor hat mir gesagt: “Wollen Sie nach Griechenland fahren, um Ihre Kind zu holen?” Da habe ich gesagt, “Nein, ich will nicht nach Griechenland fahren. Ich kann dieses, äh, Land nicht mehr sehen. Und ich will in Palästina fahren, um frei zu sein”.
David Boder: Und?
Eda Button: Da hat er mir gesagt, “Wie werden Sie Ihre Kind holen?” Hab ich gesagt, “Ich fahre jetzt nach Palästina, weil der jüdische agence Palestinienne hat mir ein Permit gegeben und wir fahren alle zusammen in, nach ein paar Tage, werden wir in, äh, Palästina fahren. Und von dort werde ich versuchen, mit griechische Papiere, weil ich werde mich wieder mit mein Mann heiraten...
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: . . . und ich werde meine griechische Papiere haben, so dass ich nach Griechenland fahren, um mein Kind zu holen“.
David Boder: Aha. [unverständlich] Dennoch hat man das, hat die Sister Superior das Kind hier gebracht. Wie waren die zurück nach [Button fällt Boder ins Wort, Rest schwer verständlich]?
Eda Button: Ja. Denn ich habe gesehen, dass der, der Agence Palestinienne hat mir am letzten Moment mein Permit genommen, weil sie haben ein Telegramm erhalten, dass mein Mann hat mir ein Permit geschickt, für mich.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: In englische Konsulat.
Eda Button: Und dieses Permit, das sie, das sie halt dort hatten mir gegeben, hat man mir in ein, äh, ein andere Frau gegeben, die schon in Palästina jetzt/ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Und ich bin hier geblieben. Da habe ich wieder angefangen zum telegraphieren, um das Kind zu haben. Weil der Direktor von Joint...
Eda Button: . . . äh, Herr Grinley, wollte nach Griechenland fahren. Er ist gefahren, da hat man hier die Sekretäre, hat man hierhin telegraphiert, er sollte, wenn er wieder zurückkommt, er sollte mein Kind von, von Konvent in Saloniki nehmen, holen. Und ich habe Papiere, ich habe unterge-, unterschrieben, dass ich, ich gebe die Autorisation, mein Kind zu holen. Und ich war im Kommisär und alles war in Ordnung. Da haben die Schwestern mein Kind wieder nicht gegeben.
David Boder: Warum?
Eda Button: Weil das Kind war schwach, sie haben gesagt. Und sie hat, die Supérieure hat mir ein Telegramm geschickt, dass sie wollte selbst mein Kind im August, im August bringen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Da war ich zu der, wieder zu der Direktor von Joint, ich hab gesagt “wenn die, im August kann ich, ich habe schon eine Permit vielleicht hier, und es ist schnell noch in Palästina fahren. Und wollen Sie denn die, äh, die Schwester bringt mein Kind früher. Wollen Sie die, die Reise zahlen?“ Hat er mir der Direktor gesagt, “Ja, wir zahlen die Reise und man muss das Kind hier bringen.”
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie, wie lange ist das Kind jetzt hier?
Eda Button: Mein Kind ist seit 15 Tagen, mein Kind hier.
David Boder: Ja. Hat sich das, Sie sagen das Kind hat sich nicht an Sie gewöhnt?
Eda Button: Das Kind hat sich nicht gut gewöhnt, weil sie da, dort sehr gut, äh...
David Boder: Gehalten?
Eda Button: . . . gehalten, sehr gute Ernährung, man hat sie sehr viel geliebt. Vielleicht haben sie gesagt, dass [ich? sie?] würde nicht zurückkommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Eda Button: Sie wollten dem Kind, äh...
David Boder: Behalten.
Eda Button: . . . behalten, äh...
David Boder: Und wie, sagen Sie, hat das Kind gebetet, wie hat das Kind gebetet, wenn Sie zurück...
Eda Button: [unterbricht ihn] Mein, mein Kind hat gebetet, dass der liebe kleine Jesus von seine Mutter und seine vater, äh...
David Boder: . . . grüßen?
Eda Button: Nein, äh, [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Erhalten?
Eda Button: . . . erhalten, seine Mutter sollte viel schnell zurückkommen, seine Mutter sollte katholisch werden.
David Boder: Ja. Und das Kind sagt jetzt, dass es manchmal, manchmal sagt, dass es will zurückgehen zu den Schwestern?
Eda Button: Das Kind weil ich bin deportiert und ich habe nichts, was die Schwestern dort, sehr viel, äh...
David Boder: Gegeben haben?
Eda Button: . . . äh, Ernährung hat und besonders von mein Kind. Ich hab sie hier in [unverständlich] gebracht, man hat, der Arzt, die Ärzte haben sie ge-
David Boder: Untersucht?
Eda Button: . . . untersucht, und ich musste sie operieren lassen für Hals und Nase. Und für dass das Kind auch, dass ich habe von Moment das sie zu mir gekommen ist und sie hat gelitten, sie glaubt, dass ich habe sie schlecht gemacht. Und besonders wenn sie, die Kleine, vielleicht hat man sie gesprochen, dass die Mutter eine schlechte...
David Boder: Naja.
Eda Button: . . . ich weiß nicht, was man ihr gesagt hat. Und ich muss jetzt doch langsam, langsam mit, äh, viel geben, mit viel, äh...
David Boder: Mit viel Aufmerksamkeit [beide sprechen gleichzeitig]...
Eda Button: . . . mit Aufmerksamkeit und langsam wird sie, wird das Kind zu mir gehören. Aber...
David Boder: [unverständlich]. Ja?
Eda Button: Das Kind liebt sehr für die Schwestern. Und sehr viel gebetet/bedeutet [unklar]. Und ich hab sie diese Woche in die jüdische, äh...
David Boder: Synagoge?
Eda Button: . . . Schwestern. Und sehr viel gebetet/bedeutet [unklar]. Und ich hab sie diese Woche in die jüdische, äh...
Eda Button: Synagoge gebracht und ich habe gesagt, Du sollst hier beten. Ein Kind betet [?] in Synagoge zu den Vater.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, das wird schon alles gut werden Mrs. Button. Ich danke Ihnen sehr. Das ist eine sehr wichtige Geschichte, die Sie uns erzählt haben.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 26. There are additional twen—, hm, twelve minutes of wire on it that will have to be rewound. It’s Illinois Institute of Technology recording, wire recording of a Greek Jewish woman, Eda Button, of 34 years old, who now has, eh, whom now her child was returned that was kept in a convent in Saloniki. And she plans to reunite herself with her husband in Tel Aviv whom she will have to remarry because for needs of, for expediency she divorced him in Greece.
David Boder: [In German] Danke sehr Frau Button.